Thank you for having me today
My name is Akiko Yamamoto as introduced today
I’ll be presenting to a crowd from a completely different field
I will be talking about my lifestyle
I find it a hard topic to talk about
I find it easier to talk about my profession
But, I’ve given the honor to speak to you today
I’d like to talk about the lifestyle of my husband and I
As mentioned earlier today
My husband is the personal trainer at XX-san’s gym
As a result I had been asked to visit today
I’m also thankful to my husband
So, let’s begin
I think we have a fitness boom now
Among the fitness trends,
I’d like to mention how I was invited to talk here
In November last year
There was a program in Nihon TV called
“1 Minute of Fukaii Hanashi”
Where my family and my husband and I were featured
When I asked how they learned about me
Someone said  there was an ophthalmologist that was also a fitness bikini model
They had  checked what's trending on social media
It is how they discovered me
I’ve brought a snippet of that program
The sound is a bit low
But please take look
I have gained 7 kilos since then
A bit embarrassing
It would have been better if I wore my swimsuit
And show my abs
But my trainer forbid me to
Because of this program
As a program on a popular time slot
I was very thankful, as an ophthalmologist
As well as a fitness bikini athlete
I’ve had many opportunities to talk like today
It has been a grateful experience
It will be quick today, but before I get to our main story today
I’d like for you to learn about us a bit more
I’ve prepared a couple of slides
Thank you in advance for having us again
I was born in Ageo City in Saitama Prefecture
I was born between my parents,
and my father ran an ENT clinic
I am the third and youngest born,
and a stereotypical youngest child
I did whatever I wanted
And was a free spirit, a daydreamer
I had happened to go to an elementary school
that was strong in in gymnastics
So, by the 4th grade it was normal to be able to do a backflip
I was at that level of gymnastics
I thought that was normal at the time
Then I joined the gymnastics club when I entered High School
Since there was a gymnastics club
I said that I was going to be a gymnast
Then I joined a band
I really got into it
So, I said that I was going to be a singer
I would talk about my typical teenage girl dream with my family
After a while my sister and my brother had started medical school
I saw them, and I started to lean towards being a doctor
During my summer break in High School,
I told my father about this
He was surprised
And said that he thought I wanted to be
a singer and a gymnast
I thought that I had to put my hobbies aside
And got serious about studying
But my parents said that maybe I could sing, dance,
and be a doctor at the same time
My parents weren’t as strict about studying all the time
So I was able to continue my hobbies and pursue medicine
This was in 1989
I enrolled in Kanazawa Medical School
I didn’t do very well in school
But I was fortunate to have friends that looked after me
And I was able to graduate in 6 years
I then entered the ophthalmologic class of the same university
I stayed there for 9 years
I did cataract surgeries and retinal detachment surgeries
In the university hospital
I studied under a professor who specialized in dry eyes,
The surface of our eye has contact with our eyelids all the time
I started to get very interested in eyelids
There are cases where the eyelids are formed downward,
or there are eyelashes that are upside down turned inside
There are many troubles that come with eyelids
In Kanazawa University, there was no specialization in this
So I thought of making one
I decided to go back to Tokyo or Kanto
I was able to meet great people
And I was able to receive great mentorship
to gain skills in eye surgery
After about a year, I went back to Kanazawa University
And started an eye surgery clinic
I still go there once a month
I visit for surgeries and the like
On the other hand in Tokyo
I had started an eye clinic in Jiyugaoka
This year will be our 12th year
I have also been very blessed with staff
I am grateful to be working in this great environment
This is my main profession
About how my husband and I met
When I went back to Tokyo
I was actually looking for a handsome
surfer instructor at the time
We got introduced
He is actually 9 years younger
But he’s actually a man of the world,
and with strong character
We have a 9 year age gap but
As the youngest child I can be less reliable
so we compliment each other well
After we were in a relationship
I learned that his mother had given birth to him at 19
So, we are 9 years apart,
but I’m only 10 years apart from his mother
I get along with him, but sometimes
relate more to his mother’s stories
When we talk about nostalgic topics,
his mother and I get along better
That was the funny story of my step mother and I
Around the time we started dating
I started to also get into beauty treatment clinics
After work I would go to these clinics everyday
The clinic I went to was not the luxurious type
When you go in, you have to change into paper underwear
There were a lot of women and it was like a hot sauna
With women doing different beauty treatments
It looked like a training hall
There was also a contest that went on
And everyone worked hard towards that
During this time, dieting was also part of this
I feel embarrassed as a doctor
But there sometimes I wouldn’t
get my period for 3 months
I did this, and got to this point I couldn’t
get a good grasp of the situation
And didn’t know when to stop
I thought that if I went back to normal food I would get fat
I felt that my way of thinking
had derailed from normal as well
During this time I became pregnant with my daughter
I immediately stopped caring about my diet
During this time,
Nicole Richie who I really liked was also pregnant
Maternity fashion was also trendy during this time
And I really got into this
I immersed myself into it
I was very happy and fulfilled
But when I was pregnant,
I gained weight in my upper body quickly
A lot of weight was on my hip joint
I started to feel the pain and I couldn’t walk for long
When I went to an orthopedist
I was diagnosed with acetabular dysplasia on both sides
This bone in my buttocks,
and this round bone in my thighs
This bone head
The cover here, if it is normal it is supposed to cover properly
The coverage on mine was shallow
Since I had gained weight on my upper body
there is contact here
The cartilage had also become scoffed, and I was feeling pain
This was on both sides
The right side’s bones were definitely touching
There was cavity in the bones
I had to get surgery as soon as possible
And the cause was
The wrong diet I was doing for a long time
had pushed this to happen
Because of this, my bones had been hollow
When it comes to diets
Following the wrong diet is very bad
I really regretted this at the time
There are two types of surgery to chose from
One is the prosthesis,
the surgery often done with the elderly
This is where they would create an artificial hip
The other method is by keeping your own bones
This is very hard and recovery time is very slow
But after the recovery from the surgery,
there are no limitations in lifestyle
It is still best to have your own bones
There is that method
However, there is the bed ridden recovery time
after the surgery for at least two months
My daughter was still 2 years old at the time
so this felt like a life sentence to me
I did not think I can be staying in a hospital bed
for two months for recovery
I kept searching online and found a doctor
in Gifu Prefecture that allowed a quicker recovery
It would cut your own bones but also take care of it
and found a way to allow a much faster recovery
I decided to have a consultation
And decided immediately to take the surgery with the doctor
The picture on the right is after surgery
And as you can see on the right it is overlapped nicely
In the surgery they hollow out your bones and move its position
Then push it into place
My husband used to work in a commercial production company
And he finished work very late
He treated my hip joint problem
Not as my problem,
but something that we had to face as a family
He resigned from his job
And helped out with housework and bringing up our child
Sorry, I get teary-eyed when talking about this
He quit his job for our family
Even when I had my surgery
He had come to Gifu with me
He took care of our daughter,
and came to visit the hospital everyday
Our daughter also had to suddenly stop breast milk
I think it was hard for him
But he put her to bed every night
I am very thankful for that
Let’s stop talking about this then
Please wait
It usually takes two weeks of hospitalization to recover
But because I wanted to be with my family
I was able to be discharged after 9 days
The right picture is not my scar right after the surgery
It’s actually after a little while
I had this massive scar
I was quite shocked when I saw this scar
The doctor also said that
That this condition isn't necessarily OK by only one surgery
I had surgery done on my right side
But I might need to do surgery on my left side someday
To delay the risks of getting re-surgery
on my right and another surgery on my left
I was advised to start strength training
as part of my rehabilitation
Because of this,
my husband had gotten a license in physical therapy
He also worked to get a license to be a trainer
That is what he did
Every night he would work on parts that hurt on my body
He also became my trainer
Ever since he did study abroad
He liked doing strength training
Working in a production company is very hard physically
Everything in your life including eating becomes chaotic
This is what his body became like then
Since after he resigned
He became like this
How long did this take?
About 2 years
My weight was the same in both pictures
That’s really good isn’t it
In 2 years time this is what change can do
He isn’t unhealthy
I think he is very healthy
In 2015, my husband joined the
Best Body Japan bodybuilding contest
There were many in my husbands class
It was a fierce competition
But he was able to be a finalist
This right back pose, I think it looks very good
During this time
I was busy with the two kids
and taking video and pictures at the same time
During this back pose The whole crowd went wild
Most of the people were male
Everyone cheered and I had goosebumps all over
That husband of mine has a gym in Roppongi
If any of you are interested,
please come and have a chat
As I mentioned earlier
My husband would be my physical therapist at night
And in the gym he is also my trainer
I have been to physical therapy regularly before
But your body goes back if you only go to the therapist
By having some muscles around
The parts the therapist fixes also become harder to go back
I was also able to realize this
I stopped feeling the pain in my hip joint
I was very thankful for that
My physical appearance too
I was conscious about my bow leg before
But it started to form better after
My buttocks had also been saggy
And, I felt that it started to go up
After 1 year and a half of training
My abs started to show
We started to see this
And, since I was already training for rehabilitation
We thought that it would be good
if there was another goal for it
We talked about me joining a tournament
As advised by my husband
I didn’t think I would have a chance
When I went to cheer my husband when he joins
I have seen the great bodies of many of them
I didn’t think someone like me could compete
I was very anxious and worried
But I trusted my husband that everything was going to be fine
I did everything my husband told me to do
And worked studiously on training
Every aspect of it is very detailed
Of course the diet and training menu
But I had to lose body fat and weight by a certain day
And it was also featured on the TV program
how he managed everything in my day-to-day life
Sort of like my manager
It is great isn’t it
For someone like myself that has a sloppy personality,
I was very thankful
In 2016, I took part in a total of 4 competitions
The very right was my first competition
The diving board of the swimming pool side worked as the stage
In a really small space, while there was rain, the wind was also really hard
And I was in 18 cm heels
We were shaking while doing poses
I was very nervous
During the preliminary
My husband said I was looking at the judges like a murderer
Since I had worked this hard
I should relax and smile more
This is the advise I got from my husband
I took part in the finals very relaxed
I received 3rd place
I am in the middle, but this is the 3rd place
From right it is 1st, 2nd, 3rd, 4th, and 5th
I won 3rd place in my first competition
I think that wasn’t such a bad result
2 years ago was the best result I got
It was at the Model Japan contest
But even how hard I work
With my physical build
There are contests that will not evaluate it very well
This is what I thought
And my husband also said to change the competitions we join
I chose to take part in competitions that
Evaluate athletes based on weights and proper training
There is the Japan Body Building & Fitness Moderation
competition
It’s a big tournament called All Japan
During this time, it is September 3rd
I received the 4th place last year
Since this competition
I had been featured on Fukaii Hanashi
And I have gotten to speak with a lot of different people
But the 4th place isn’s so bad
But during this time
I was quite greedy, and wanted to get a medal
I wanted to be able to give the medal to my husband
I wanted to bring that to this years competition
And work hard to win
Sorry for the long explanation
But for my training
He is quite popular these days
My personal trainer
He said  since I got 4th place in All Japan
I should be able to train on my own
He would still make my training program menu
If my shoulders looked weak,
he would add training for my shoulders
And makes my menu,
so in a way I am at my husband’s gym
And I train like this
In the past, I only had Wednesdays off
That was the only time given to me
I would do my entire body for about 2 to 3 hours straight
I had great focus then
But I cannot do it this way now
Because I need to do more weights for the competitions
I need to focus on individual parts of my body
like shoulders and buttocks separately
On the weekends I would do training with my kids
We have fun doing it
Before the competition
When there aren’t patients around
And during lunch breaks are also an important time
They also featured this during the TV program
Please take a look
This is for real
I do wear swimsuits normally
But we had to tone it down for TV
When I hear the voice of patients
I don’t train then
But, yes it is like this
Yes
I have introduced to you my husband earlier
I would also like to talk to you about my children
On the left is Riri who is 9 years old
The moment she was born she was very cute
She is very thoughtful towards her mother
She says that she wants to just like me when she grows up
I thought I have a successor for my clinic
But she meant a bodybuilder
She is actually better at posing than myself
On the right is Kotaro who is 6 years old
His face, and his all out youngest child
personality is just like me
And he says that he wants to be like
his sister Riri when he grows up
He really looks up to his sister
Lately he has been getting into Kamen Rider
So I am relieved his gender is leaning towards male
These two kids
Many have told me that I was doing such a good job
being ophthalmologist and body builder and a mother
But this is what my week looks like
Monday, Tuesday, Thursday, Friday
and bi weekly on Saturdays
I work from 10:30 AM to 7PM
Riri is in 4th grade in elementary
She has cram school and ballet classes
In actual, my daughter is more busy than I am
This part is my training
This is my training menu
This part, my trainer my husband sets up everything
The program changes
When competitions are near
When he sees that I am not losing weight as I should
He would add cardio in the morning
When you look at this, you might think that I am doing well
But actually, my family that supports me are the ones doing very well
Without their support I would not be able to do this
My husband would really want to join competition himself
But he has focused on me after taking 4th place
I also have a ticket to join the All Japan next year
He really thinks of me first
Our kids now are both in Elementary school
But when they were in preschool
He would send them off  and wash the dishes in the morning
And throw the trash away
I saw this on the news before but
the most common household chore
Japanese women want their husbands
to do is throw away the trash
That is a daily thing for us
And I thought if that was enough
My husband, as you saw the schedule earlier
There were only items that the children or I do are written down
But my husband takes care of his things on his own
I am very thankful for that
Before tournaments
I don’t do a very good job as a mother
And I am able to do things because of this family
I am very grateful
Every time that I cannot get the 1st place
I feel bad because I let my children down
After a competition
We have an awarding ceremony done by our kids
It is adorable please let me share this
I may need to pixelate this
But yes, this reminds me
When you get first place the sash and the gold medal
All of them are gold
So my son has a thing for gold now
He always says that he wants gold
So my motivation
Comes a lot from my son’s words that he only wants gold
This leads my motivation before a competition
I am a selfish mother that does whatever
But the moment the competition finishes,
the priority immediately changes to my family
With that I have gained about 7 kilos right now
But for our children
Even when they see their parents work hard
even when they are still small
We are hoping that it becomes a positive influence on them
Not just with studies
I want them to be able to give even play their 100%
This is how we are
My husband looks like he was bullied to do it
But this is how we raise our children
Yes
I’ve shared my husband’s and my instagram account
Please check it out if you’re interested
Thank you very much
Sorry if I was rambling